Samantha is in New York City hi Samantha
how are you I'm doing great babe how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up
actually I have a credit card that is
now in collections and they want to
settle the debt I actually just gave him
a call right before I called you and the
debt amount is for 2,600 I don't have
that money I tried to negotiate they
said they will only go down to 75% of it
which would be like 1,900 I'm working by
you know I tried doing credit counseling
and are you but I'm about six months at
least behind okay why are you behind I
was working full-time I lost my job
sorry and I'm so behind on everything I
know got a job again and now working
that's guys like not much are you making
at your job um about 1500 a month no
time pretty freaking scary isn't it
oh my gosh you have no idea yeah I've
been there
how old are you 23 okay you're on your
own
obviously yeah yep what part of New York
do you live in actually live on Long
Island and you're trying to do it on
1,500 a month that's gonna be tough to
in it oh yeah I'm not sure what are your
leaving what are your living
arrangements I actually will live with
my parents
that's good news okay yeah so you do
have some support in that regard
yeah they've been really good to me that
is that is good and how much other debt
do you have um I said I have um how
about maybe a I have other credit cards
about 500 at 5000m hmm um yeah uh what
that do you have a card debt yes yes I
do I have an auto loan for about 900
another you know sagen how much I own
9,500 yeah 9,500 on the Ottomans all
right I'll tell you what hold on
this break because I don't want to leave
you hanging I want to give you a good
solid answer because you're in a tough
place and we're gonna walk out of this
together can you hang with me
sure be right back joining us America
this is the Dave Ramsey show talking
with Samantha in New York Long Island
New York 23 years old has moved back in
with her mom and dad she lost her job
now she's gotten a new job but she got
six months behind on a credit card bill
that she owes 2600 on they're offering
her a 75% settlement she's also got a
$5,000 credit card and a $9,500 car loan
and she was pretty scared at one point
in this process is that a fair summary
what you told me oh absolutely yeah the
four thousand actually in other credit
cards that just across a couple of
different ones oh okay okay yeah all
right
so if we add all of this up you've got
about sixteen thousand dollars in credit
card debt and car loan yeah and you're
making $1,500 a month is $18,000 a year
and is that 1500 take-home or is that -
taxes that's like a estimated take-home
yeah okay Sal and is that a 40-hour a
week job uh yeah it's like 38 hours so
it's about yet full-time okay good good
okay well when I was 28 years old I went
completely broke and lost everything my
wife and I ended up being losing I mean
having houses foreclosed on going all
the way down we were scared out of our
minds with a brand-new baby and a
toddler it was I was 25 years ago but I
still remember it like it was 20 minutes
ago because I remember that how your
feels to have your stomach up in your
throat where you can chew on it it's
unbelievable so I know exactly how you
feel
the what we what we what I would do is
this your first goal is to make sure
that the car is current is it yes good
so you've managed to keep that current
and then are you behind on the other
credit cards no actually I'm I'm
up-to-date and I'm working the sale ball
okay all right so you've already heard
about the debt snowball yes I have I'm
actually I've been listening for about a
year now since I'm Holly okay
good alright and so and by being with
your parents you don't have any expenses
as long as you don't go out on the town
yes yes long as you keep your social
life to a minimum or make yourself a
life things that doesn't cost money
anyway okay and then you can work your
way through this so I'm not real uh you
don't have any cash saved today do you I
have baby step number one I have a
thousand dollars in my emergency fund
and then after that I have $150 150 oh
no 750 okay so you can't accept their
offer any way today no okay
and and I would just let them know that
just say I can't I can't do anything
today but I'm working with you and I'll
what I can do is if you can drop the
offer I'll continue to save and I think
I can get back with you in about two
more months and I think I'm going to
make you a good strong offer then it
won't be nineteen hundred but I think I
can probably get you you know
twenty-five or thirty cents on the
dollar who's the card with uh it was a
gap card de Bank okay good yeah okay
here's what they're gonna do they're
just going to continue to bug the crap
out of you okay and they already are on
Earth Day yeah they've been sending me
letters yeah but I mean are they guys
they got a phone number on you they
actually don't cuz my phone numbers
changed so that's good good good they
don't need one because they will come
back 26 times a day okay so what I do
want you to pay the bill and you want to
pay the bill but today you don't have it
so if you have a twenty six hundred
dollar bill that's seven or eight months
behind with a credit card you can offer
them thirty forty cents on the dollar
and they will take it and so what we're
talking about here's thousand you know
bucks or so they'll probably take that
once you get that together so once you
scratch together a thousand you can call
them up and say now again I give you the
thousand now there's two things you
probably remember if you've been
listening you do not give them
electronic access to a checking account
and you do not give them any money until
you have the settlement offer accepted
in writing
can be by email that's fine but you need
a written thing that you can print off
and staple a copy of the cashier's check
or the money order to it so you can keep
that in a file for the rest of your life
okay okay and then you're going to say
you're going to work up and stay current
with these others and let's pile up a
little money and settle this one and
then let's continue to work the debt
snowball now here's a big question of
the day have you learned your lesson
on being deeply in debt absolutely once
you get this paid off you're never
borrowing again no I've already done my
plastic ectomy have cut them all up so
and same with the car because here's the
deal if you you know if you had had
$10,000 cash saved in an emergency fund
and had no debt you would be having a
completely different life right now
wouldn't you yes I would be and so
that's where I want to get you to and
keep you there for the rest of your life
so these things when they happen are
horrible and going through this is a
pile of crap but the trick is don't have
you don't want to learn these lessons
twice so go ahead go ahead and get the
lesson out of it and fit be finished
with it you know never again going back
now do you know what Financial Peace
University is our nine week series yes I
actually signed up and up in certain
class March night there you go good
you're ahead of me I was going to give
it to you because I because I'm proud of
your doing a lot of good stuff so
Samantha here's what I predict I predict
you're probably going to take an extra
job to earn some extra income in
addition to this at night and I think
you're going to have all of this debt
100% of it paid in less than a year okay
good that's what I predict and then I
think you're going to go on to build an
emergency fund and this horrible time
that when you're 33 you look back on the
time that you were 23 and you're
unemployed and you learned these lessons
and someone tries to get you to borrow
money you're going to just run from them
screaming yeah that's all right I'm glad
your mom and dad were there for a
temporary safety net and give you a
chance to get this mess cleaned up and
then get back out on your own and and
I'm glad we were able to help you with a
couple of things with the radio show and
with the class so glad we were here for
you hey thanks for the call
and if you need some more help
you get scared you call me anytime
that's what we're here for
you